When we're looking
at polar coordinates,
one of the important issues is
to understand the unit vectors.
Let's describe our
coordinate system, again.
We have a point where
there is an object.
And at this point, we have a
pair of unit vectors, r hat
and theta hat.
Now those unit vectors
will change, depending
on where you are in space.
We now want to
address the question,
how do I compare
polar coordinates
and Cartesian coordinates.
In Cartesian coordinates,
at this point
here, we would have-- let's say
we choose a Cartesian plus x
and plus y, then we would have
a unit vector i hat and j hat.
And how are these
vectors related?
Remember our angle theta, so
we have the angle theta here
and the angle theta there.
And now I would like to apply
a simple vector decomposition
to r hat and theta hat and
express each of these unit
vectors in terms of the unit
vectors i hat and j hat.
Let's begin with r hat.
As you can see in
the diagram, r hat
has a horizontal component
and a vertical component.
So what we have is r hat.
It's a unit vector,
so its length is 1.
Its horizontal component
is adjacent to the angle,
so that's cosine of theta i
hat plus sine of theta j hat.
The vertical component
is opposite the angle.
In a similar fashion,
theta hat-- well, theta hat
has a component in the
negative i hat direction,
which is opposite the angle.
And it has a component in
the positive j hat direction,
which is adjacent to the angle.
So we have minus sine theta i
hat plus cosine theta j hat.
And that's how we can
decompose our unit vectors r
hat and theta hat in terms
of Cartesian coordinates.
Now why is this significant?
Because if we're describing
the motion of an object,
for instance, an object
that's going around a circle,
then our polar coordinate
theta is a function of time.
And so these unit vectors are
actually changing in direction.
You saw that before.
Over here, r hat and theta hat
point in different directions.
So what we actually have as
functions of time is r hat of t
equals cosine theta of t i hat.
Now the unit
vectors don't change
in Cartesian coordinates.
At every single point, you
have the same Cartesian unit
vectors.
And so this vector
is time dependent.
Now the significance of that
is our first important vector
in kinematics is
the position vector.
The position vector
is a vector that
goes from the origin
to where the object is.
We'll call that r of t.
So this position vector r of t
can be expressed as a length r.
And its direction is
in the r hat direction,
which is a function of time.
So we have r cosine
theta of t i hat
plus r sine theta of t j hat.
Now we can now define the
velocity of this object
where the velocity is the
derivative of the position
vector.
When you differentiate,
remember, r is a constant,
so we get r.
Now what is the
derivative with respect
to time of cosine theta t.
Because the argument of
theta is a function of t,
we need to use the chain rule.
So the derivative is minus sine
theta of t, d theta dt i hat.
And the derivative of
the sine is cosine theta
of t d theta dt j hat.
Now notice that I can pull out
the common term d theta dt.
So I have r d theta dt.
And I have minus sine theta
of t i hat plus cosine
theta of t j hat.
And if you'll notice, this is
exactly the unit vector theta
hat.
So we can write
our velocity vector
for this object that's moving in
a circle as r d theta dt theta
hat.
When we write a
vector like this,
it's pointing tangentially,
the theta hat direction,
and this part is the component.
So often we can use a
notation v theta theta
hat, where v theta is the
component r d theta dt.
Now this component can be
positive or negative or 0.
For example, if d theta dt is
positive, what does that mean?
That means that
our angle theta is
increasing so the object is
moving the way I indicate
with my finger.
If d theta dt is 0, then
the angle is not changing,
so the object is at rest.
And finally, if d
theta dt is negative,
then the angle
theta is decreasing,
and so the object is
moving in this direction.
So this is our velocity for
a circular motion expressed
in polar coordinates.